please good sir i beseech you as a man
of science nay as a man of reason you
mustn't stifle my research at this
critical juncture you have no idea how
close i am to finding a cure for this
blasted pestilence i need only a handful
of live subjects to complete my research
the plague doctor's emphatic pleas fell
on deaf ears as a stone-faced researcher
took notes on his latest pontifications
the doctor whom these clods had reduced
so rudely to a mere number
scp-049 banged his gloved fist up
against the wall and to think he once
thought of these men as intellectual
equals fellow travelers on the road to
scientific enlightenment what a
positively sick joke before the doctor
got another chance to appeal for his
right to experiment the researcher left
him alone once more a truly sad state of
affairs nobody appreciated a true
scientist in this day and age it was
sure to be another day of languishing
alone in this cell wishing he had the
capacity to do more so he was surprised
as anyone when the alarm started going
off and the door of his cell swung open
automatically the plague doctor stepped
out of his cell and into the hall where
many other humanoid anomalies were
roaming confused as to why they'd been
suddenly released what was happening as
it turned out what was happening was one
of the most brutal chaos insurgency
raids the staff of site 19 had ever seen
it had been planned immaculately you see
guards rotate semi-regularly at site 19
due to the high pressure nature of the
job lots of deaths and mental breakdowns
as you probably correctly predicted even
the administrative staff of the scp
foundation are only human well mostly
anyway so they're not immune to little
oversights here and there and it's in
those oversights that expertly trained
chaos insurgency infiltration agents
make their living no less than 15 of
them had been working undercover in site
19 for just over two weeks and they did
a fine job of lowering the metaphorical
drawbridge for a heavily armed invasion
force the guards who weren't plants were
quickly murdered by the infiltrators and
even some of the on-site task forces
were quickly overwhelmed and gunned down
by the high-precision rifles of the
chaos insurgency's finest while the
frontliners were distracted by the
sudden assault the infiltrators found
their way to the site's security control
room and massacred everyone inside
opening every single door in the site
was as simple as putting in a few stolen
key codes and flipping a few carefully
remembered switches consequently while
foundation agents and cast insurgency
mercenaries clashed sabres high priority
anomalies like scp-049 simply wandered
the facility watching the calamity
unfold within the foundation was beset
on all sides shot at by heavily armed
maniacs and attacked from within by the
numerous roaming anomalous entities that
were eager to get their hands on
foundation personnel definitely not an
ideal situation to say the least the
plague doctor only had one thing on his
mind though hmm
this definitely won't do my research any
good unless i can escape and find my way
to a suitable laboratory oh now there is
an idea but his scientific fantasies
were soon interrupted by a chaos
insurgency soldier swinging the butt of
his m4 carbine into his avian exo skull
with a supremely unpleasant crack the
doctor was dazed by it momentarily the
pain coming at him like a thunderclap
but the insurgent never got the chance
to take another swing before the
insurgent could do anything the plague
doctor lunged out with practice speed
grasping him by the throat immediately
everything went black and the
insurgent's limp corpse collapsed to the
ground sir
the doctor internally mused soldiers
attacking medics is violating even the
most basic rules of gentlemanly warfare
then another flash of immense pain has a
different rifle but collided with the
back of his head the doctor fell to one
knee feeling dizzy but before he could
retaliate he felt the two sharp prongs
of a cattle prod pressing up against his
neck the sudden rush of electricity
surged through his neck sending his
muscles into a wave of involuntary
spasms the insurgents crowding around
him chimed in with their own agonizing
cattle prods relentlessly shocking him
until the flashes of white-hot pain soon
became an oppressive blanket of total
dark even on his most cantankerous days
the scp foundation had never treated him
like this when he eventually came to he
was still in darkness standing upright
with high-tech shackles holding every
limb in place it was beyond
uncomfortable for the poor plague doctor
but it succeeded in the task of keeping
him under control he couldn't move an
inch there were muffled voices beyond
the dark beyond the confines of this new
containment the modulated gas mask
voices of insurgents and something else
faintly accented oddly familiar but he
couldn't quite place it soon the voices
were replaced by another sound the
grinding of crowbars levering nails out
of cheap wood with a creaking tumble a
rectangle of bright light opened up in
front of him populated by a number of
silhouettes on either side were chaos
insurgents in familiar tactical garb and
in between them stood a tall well
groomed man with an expensive looking
purple smoking jacket and a pencil
moustache for a few fractions of a
second his face was a portrait of
excitement but as he took in the sight
of the plague doctor standing before him
all the joy drained from his snooty
continents what the hell am i looking at
here the man in the smoking jacket said
the doctor indignant had such a response
from the man who'd presumably ordered
his assault rasp a man of saiyans could
sir the man in the smoking jacket
ignored him and continued to berate the
chaos insurgents with an odd level of
confidence for someone reprimanding
trained cold-blooded killers i wanted
scp-650 the startling statue not this
clownish renfair cosplayer what the hell
did i pay you ruffians for i was told
you chaos insurgents were the very best
at this and for your empty price i
expect excellence the rent continued
much like this leaving everyone in
attendance the insurgents the plague
doctor feeling thoroughly exhausted by
him and unable to do anything about it
you see this wasn't just any chaos
insurgency client your average tin pot
dictator or arms dealer you know the
time this was the one and only pascal
legate one of the most famous or rather
infamous anarch collectors in the game
he'd been a founding person of interest
for years due to his dealings with the
chaos insurgency and marshall carter and
dark limited all to the end of expanding
his anarch collection but his vast
wealth and connections had always
shielded him from foundation probes for
those unfamiliar with the subculture
anart short for anomalous art is exactly
what it sounds like artistic projects
with anomalous properties to give it
that extra kick one of the most popular
groups of interest dealing in anart is
the iconic are we cool yet which
incidentally had recently excommunicated
pascal leget for being an exceedingly
wealthy uptight square who really didn't
represent the collective's rebellious
ethos and considering his response was
to pay the chaos insurgency to raid site
19 for a few pieces for his own private
collection costing him millions of
dollars in both groups many lives it was
safe to say he wasn't taking it well
look we got to that other statue and
that thing killed four of our best guys
so how about we just call it even said
one of the insurgents i'm sure you can
have fun with bird brain here too pascal
tutted and reluctantly dismissed the
higher guns having the plague doctor
here definitely wasn't ideal especially
considering he wanted to host the
ultimate anart exhibition to put are we
cool yet worthless some new develo
magnifique to shame but he would make do
with what he had perhaps he could say
that 049 was a commentary on the
ever-present nature of disease in
mankind's life and our forever archaic
approach to it yes yes that would do
nicely needless to say the plague doctor
was infuriated by all this the violence
against his person the kidnapping the
disrespect and most of all the
interruption to his precious research
especially considering how close he'd
gotten to finding a cure for the
pestilence but instead he was soon
spirited by a legion of heavily armed
goons from his wooden box to a glass one
in one of leget's many opulent hallways
there were other glass cases on either
side of him and more on the other side
of the hall all too reinforced for the
plague doctor to even smash through it
on his own damn it leget's own private
anarch exhibition probably wedged
between his oversized dining room and
his jewel encrusted crapper occasionally
pascal himself would jaunt down the
hallway to gaze upon his new stolen
anarch pieces and of course the plague
doctor would try his best to reason with
him i am a patient man monsieur leget
but this is simply barbaric by what
right do you imprison me here is your
intention to deprive the world the
entire human race of my valuable medical
breakthroughs could you live with that
on your conscience good sir there was
never any meaningful response the plague
doctors soon learned that pascal leget
didn't like his art interactive it was
simply meant to languish away in a glass
box being watched being passively looked
at those chaos insurgency loutz hadn't
even bothered to bring his notebook or
medical bag so he was without the tools
to even perform his experiments as
loathed as he was to admit it this was
even worse than being mocked up by the
scp foundation but all this wasn't
entirely unfamiliar there was something
in the glass box across from the plague
doctor that he vaguely recognized back
from site 19. he'd never seen it up
close but he'd heard researchers
speaking about it and even seen a few
pictures and such a strange construction
it was a peculiar haphazard sculpture
made from concrete rebar and spray paint
quite ugly in this humble doctor's
opinion but there was something oddly
entrancing about it and for reasons
beyond the doctor's recollection four of
leget's men stood around the glass box
in where it was being stored always
watching the man were frequently
switched in and out as though they were
watching in shifts always fixing their
gaze on its peculiar malformed body
maybe it was all the electrical shocks
and knocks to the head but he just
couldn't remember why pascal was having
the piece so carefully observed but he
knew on some primal level that the
secret to this would perhaps be the key
to his own escape if only he could
remember still time passed pascal
drifted in and out sometimes with guests
the plague doctor had learned not to
speak these animals could not be
reasoned with as a scientist he would
instead carefully observe until his
observations bore fruit he noticed that
pascal's guests all people who looked
equally as wealthy and pompous as pascal
himself all seemed to look right over
him and instead focus on the ugly statue
across the hall still forever observed
by any four of pascal's men some of them
looked actively nervous just being in
its presence curious the plague doctor
made a mental note of this just as he
did when pascal gave his guests a
reassuring pat on the shoulder and told
them please calm yourself it's harmless
while my personnel are keeping an eye on
it little by little the plague doctor's
memories of his infamous neighbor had
begun to return he knew what he must do
to escape now all he needed to do was
wait for the perfect moment soon enough
pascal's mansion was filled with a bevy
of anarch snobs from hither and yarn a
private soiree to show off his new
collection they wandered the halls in
three-piece tuxedos and designer
ballroom dresses sipping champagne from
imported crystal all such lovely refined
high society people and if the good
doctor's plan went off as he intended
they would all be such lovely refined
high society corpses the plague doctor
waited until mercifully he and the four
members of personnel watching the
sculpture were the only ones left in the
hallway he'd been so good so patient
that none of the men guarding the
sculpture at present had ever heard him
make a noise he was so invisible to them
that in all likelihood they probably
didn't even notice he could make a sound
and that worked for his purposes just
fine though in any case if he wanted
this to work he would need to time his
plan perfectly even a fraction of a
second out of place and the whole thing
would have dire consequences still the
doctor was still a frenchman at heart
and as a frenchman he knew he would
rather die nobly in the process of
escape than remain captured by this
worthless buffoon he'd be sure to take
as many of these men down with him in
the process as he was able the plague
doctor exhaled deeply drawing a lung
full of air then bellowed as loud as he
possibly could the sudden unexpected
noise was so shocking that it jogged the
four watchers almost reflexively to turn
and look at him and in the split second
that they did the plague doctor closed
his eyes in the dark times seemed to
move slower perhaps due to the doctor's
keen focus cultivated over many a
century he listened carefully to the
sequence of sounds glass shattering four
choked gasps in sequence for brutal
crunches then nanoseconds later more
glass shattering the plague doctor's
eyes snapped open just in time just as
predicted the sculpture being entirely
unobserved had smashed through its glass
case murdering all four members of
personnel by snapping their necks and
then smashed through his own glass case
to do the same to him the plague doctor
had cut it so close in fact that he
opened his eyes to the face of the
sculpture staring into his own its
concrete limbs wrapped around his neck
very good timing indeed with a sigh of
relief the plague doctor slipped out of
the sculpture's concrete grasp and back
down the hallway keeping his gaze fixed
on the sculpture the entire time he'd
heard it decimate pascal's men he
certainly didn't fancy undergoing the
same fate the second the plague doctor
backed around the corner rendering the
sculpture or as the scp foundation
called it
scp-173 out of sight he could hear
terrified screaming coming from the
other end of the hall he was not a
sadistic man but the plague doctor would
be lying if he told you he didn't take
just a little bit of pleasure in hearing
that sound somewhere else in the vast
mansion of pascal leget the sculpture
was slaughtering its way through
servants and party guests while the
plague doctors searched for some kind of
exit anyone who dared get in this way
was given a swift and merciless touch of
death sending their body unceremoniously
to the ground anyone in his way was
preventing him from finding a cure for
the pestilence and thus endangering
countless lives it was of course
regrettable to have to kill anyone but
some sacrifices must be made for the
greater good of mankind well it's not
necessarily always regrettable per se on
his way out while the murderous rampage
of scp-173 seemed to distract anyone of
note the plague doctor just so happened
to encounter a fleeing pascal legate
hoping to find some kind of escape
himself
it seemed that now fate was on his side
once more to have his jailer right here
in the palm of his hand would be such a
perfect parting gift funnily enough
pascal was far more talkative to him now
he rattled off a rapid-fire series of
threats bribes and pleas claiming in the
end that he never meant any harm he was
the one who freed the plague doctor from
the scp foundation
they were on the same side here all this
was for the art no offense was ever
intended pascal legette simply lived for
art then die for it
the plague doctor said and with a single
touch pascal's eyes rolled up into the
back of his head and he fell to the
ground dead it was one of the few
non-scientific deaths that he felt truly
no guilt for after some time searching
the screams around the rest of the
mansion eventually went silent that did
wonders for his focus it didn't take
long for the plague doctor to locate an
exit a fine mahogany door with elaborate
adornments befitting a man as gaudy as
pascal and began strolling towards it
his chest swollen with pride and a sense
of accomplishment then he blinked and a
few feet in front of him stood the
sculpture it was there so suddenly that
the plague doctor fell backwards in
shock but he devoted everything to
keeping an eye on that monstrosity with
everyone else in the mansion presumably
dead at this point it had now come back
for him it stood there staring silently
ready to exact the terrible price for
freeing it as soon as the doctor dared
to blink the plague doctor began
crawling backwards down the hall just
wanting to put some distance between
himself and the sculpture as the seconds
passed he could feel his eyes drying out
until the inevitable blink the sculpture
was standing right in front of him now
gazing down almost mocking it had closed
the distance so quickly if the plague
doctor blinked again he was sure that
his eyes would never open again all it
had to do was wait as the seconds passed
and the doctor began to feel his eyes
drying up again that subtle sting
quickly grew into a nagging pain that
could not be denied sooner or later he
was going to have to
bang the front door flew open and in an
instant the hallway was filled with
heavily armed troops all wearing the
familiar black and gray of the scp
foundation the plague doctor had never
been so relieved to see the organization
that had kept him locked up for so many
decades for once they'd saved him from
something even worse of course the
sculpture didn't say anything but the
disappointment of losing that one more
victim seemed to radiate off of it like
a lingering bad smell the plague doctor
willingly gave himself up and heavy
machinery was brought in to pick up
scp-173 with the help of the ipods to
make sure it didn't try any funny
business in transit pascal had gotten
away with his shady dealings for years
but the brazen attack he funded against
site 19 was now enough for the
foundation to track him down when his
corpse was found in the halls of his own
home with no obvious cause of death we
can happily tell you that nobody was
disappointed by the evening the plague
doctor was happy to be back in his cell
his research could continue here and in
time he knew that the personnel of the
scp foundation would listen to reason
and comply with his demands after all
science marches on regardless of who
chooses to march with it but he would
forever feel a little nervous in psych
19 after that knowing the concrete
monster he was sharing the building with
he hoped that if ever there was another
containment breach involving that
thing that it didn't feel like paying
him a visit for old time's sake now go
check out scp-049 the plague doctor
everything you need to know and scp-173
origin story how 173 got to site-19 for
more on the two scps from today's
original tale